oh you guys are pure class over here not
so much you with all the tattoos what do
you do sir
you're a teacher what do you teach
fifth and sixth
son he calls you gay so hard dude that
was crazy that was crazy disrespect
did you hear the way he said it he goes
art teacher like he called him the f
word right in front of his wife that's
crazy damn dude what do you do that you
get to judge this man
you're in finance I knew it was some
snobby I could tell finance that
ain't nothing to brag about in
Toledo but you manage piggy banks just
I'd like to cash out my 401k
okay
yeah you got about 3.82 cents you want
to take that dream vacation to Cleveland
you know